Now, note that once an object is being created in the environment, the
PhysicsEngine will simulate each frame, updating the position and velocity of
any physics bodies that it has in its world. In order for GRITS objects to
properly receive the data and update positions for the rendering, we need to
query the PhysicsEngine results by the physics bodies created for an entity.
Note that the position values for an object already exists as it's inherited
from our entity base class. Inside of our update loop, given that the entity
has a physical body, we can query it's position and update the entity position
accordingly. This way the visual representation of an object will match the
physical representation as is. To do this, you need to call the physics body's
GetPosition method and then assign it to our local positional values.